hello and welcome to this video the
10-man 12 the man with the 10 or plan or
run templin okay let's not get into that
too much and play one of my jersey
tzimisce variations and where you could
never quite sure probably the drawing
Raiders like zero close to that I think
okay I can try e5 here for change so
normally I take on f5 go nigeria five is
an interesting idea to play d 5 I think
these six now is good for black if i'm
not mistaken and but it's not it's not
played so chunking and OD six that was
wise idea putting the pawn all the way
up to 86 and now black ken has to deal
with the fact that the night only aid is
stuck swissco a 4 then 23
I'd see just Bishop e3 are not sure if I
want to play c4 in this position
probably not let's just develop here
yeah the night that what the night can
do in this game is to go to h5 and from
there I did some others had basically
stuck it's quite funny even the green
trade is sometimes kind of acceptable
for white in this disposition hmm maybe
I should do that at the night c3m making
sure to block sort of block on the light
squares a 6b five is not on and Queenie
for and stuff like that also I'm
impossible night be three minutes let's
cover that for the moment might be 394
that was an option and I am ok wants to
go to a 6 it seems
okay let's not does it very much it's
quite funny this position is white has
some compensation but it's difficult to
to do something something um yeah how do
you call it something constructive and
something positive but you have some
kind of yeah you have enough activity to
make it difficult for black to get
anywhere can take c5 here i'm just not
sure if I should Bishop c5 95 every five
rupee five takes TX would be one trading
a pawn down night coming to before as an
interesting interesting idea for him and
I think I just drop back
and I should go to e2 that was a
actually wanted to go to you too but
forgot about keeping c4 protected it's
not a big big thing a big big deal if he
goes green 86 I can circle Queenie too
but hmm its kind of kind of unnecessary
so what if I try to have our bishop that
doesn't really help her Bishop to h4
what is the point not playing for meat
here let's go back I was a pretty down
by DM try to get the bishop somewhere on
h4
I one day have a queen trade something
and that helped karina for king of two
kounya 3 i'm not worried about the
endgame upon down that doesn't doesn't
really matter here
knight c6 to a five in that end Garrett
that could be a problem I just try if he
wants to trade I'm not sure he wants and
okay
it's still stuck with that night IAM ok
so it gives a pawn to try to activate it
well i know i don't think it works at
all to be honest okay okay okay i kim
natured you for very interesting check
okay kicks on each 6mm how to play this
here it's not easy at all yeah 92 or 95
you will go back i think in both cases I
think he is bad actually so that I have
not G 1 2 F 3 if it goes knight c6 I got
a g1 ok didn't do that g3 or how exactly
do I play here I can also play g-form
metaphor is pretty time or a pretty wild
stuff which a trip to force kind of kind
of annoying running ok maybe I do that
what I want this I want to get it is
pawns there
it spawns on 27 and so on in route Kent
games I don't think he can just trade
everything check yeah this is an
interesting interesting thing I mean I
have no time this is probably the
biggest issue check it's it's very
difficult for him to try to win this
position because of my space advantage
and then you will play no one cannot do
that it's difficult to do at least
rookie to keene g7 however this does
hold stuff can probably never try to win
this
check for what you sound check
check check I played that very well that
end cam it wasn't easy I check check
check white forfeits on time check
that's pretty amazing that dead stuff
Ian 96 Chen Zhen so on check I don't
think I should lose really have a hard
time to think of that this should be
forced or anything but clothes difficult
and it seems that this does not work and
check is cut it covered I cannot get to
the d7 pawn the reason why I was still
pretty optimistic is that whenever the
d7 point falls it get gets very
difficult but she has it covered and
check played it very well I think check
check and check well okay played it
pretty really really really well so
probably Queen f3 was bad man the Queen
trade often is quite a decent idea in
this kind of position but g5 is just
very strong
very strong probably should prepare that
if i want to go queena three something
like this then Queen f3 it's probably
equal I mean I definitely have
compensation for the pawn but probably
I'm not not not better in a way now you
never get that night somewhere unless he
plays that that that brutal g5 move it's
funny that the engines just a 5 which
and some change this ayah mates it's a
draw that's it's just a just a draw yeah
Jack and it was really pretty brutal and
I underestimated that knight c6 that's
funny that the engine actually thinks
that this is even stronger
yeah here there's this additional I diem
they played that really well Wow okay
thanks for watching